[موسيقى]
يرى بعض الأشخاص أن الوشم يدمر
نفسك على أنه طريقة للصراخ طلبًا للمساعدة
وليس وسيلة لتقوية
نفسك
[موسيقى]
وجدت نفسي من خلال الوشم أريد أن
أعطي للمرأة هذا التعبير والقدرة
على اكتشاف من تكون
[موسيقى  ]
قالت أمي إن الوشم وصمة عار ،
عائلتي محافظة للغاية ، لقد قاموا
بتربيتي لأكون فتاة مسلمة مناسبة ،
واتضح أنني هذا الرجل الصغير الموشوم
[موسيقى]
لم أتواصل مع التستر
أو كوني شخصًا متواضعًا جدًا  كنت أرغب في
أن أكون أكثر ميلًا إلى المغامرة وأن أكون في
العالم بدلاً من أن أخفي
، لقد اخترت طريقتي الخاصة لأكون من
نوعي الجميل من المسلمين ، كنت أعرف أنه
ستكون هناك عواقب بالنسبة لي للحصول على وشم
، وبعد ذلك أصبح فنانًا للوشم.
لكنني أدركت أنني
لا أستطيع إخفاء من أنا عملت في العديد من
متاجر الوشم التي كانت حقًا
شديدة الذكورة ويهيمن عليها الذكور ، كانت
جدرانًا من الطوب الأحمر تقليديًا
وتفوح منها رائحة السجائر ، ولا يشعر الكثير من
عملائي بالراحة.  إلى
متجر وشوم عادي ، لذلك قمت بإنشاء
مساحة مقدسة كانت ناعمة
ومؤنثة بالحبر.
يأتون من
ثقافات محافظة سواء من الثقافة اليهودية أو الثقافة الإسلامية
أو هم أشخاص
ملونون يرونني ويسعون إليّ من مهمتي
هي تمكين المرأة من خلال الوشم ،
لذا فإن القليل من الناس يفعلون ما أفعله للنساء في
جميع أنحاء البلاد ومن المهم
بالنسبة لي أن أحضر  يتلاشى الحبر
ويسهل الوصول إليه ، لذا آخذ مقطعي
الدعائي حيث يكون مطلوبًا
[موسيقى]
تعطيني اليهودية إحساسًا واضحًا جدًا
بالهدف والانتماء ، لكن هناك
أسطورة تصدق أنني سأقول إنه إذا كان
لديك وشم فلا يمكنك أن تدفن  في
مقبرة يهودية ومن الصعب
حقًا قبولها طوبى لك أيها الرب الذي
يقدس وشم السبت
يجعلني أشعر بالثقة والقوة والجمال ،
أعتقد أن الرغبة في
الوشم وتحت  إن الوقوف على أن عائلتي
قد لا تقبل ذلك جعلني
أحب نفسي أكثر لأنني قادر
على القول إنك تعلم أنني أريد هذا هو
جسدي قراري اختياري
[موسيقى]
شون مسلم وأنا يهودي
ونحن  كلاهما ينتميان إلى ديانات وثقافات
لا تقبل الوشم
[الموسيقى]
ما يجعلني يهودية ليس ما أرتديه
أو ما لدي على جسدي أو
لون بشرتي إذا كان بإمكاني إظهار النساء
اليهوديات وخاصة النساء اليهوديات في  اللون نظرًا
لوجود عدد قليل جدًا منا بحيث يمكن
قبولك بوشمك ، فإن السماء
هي الحد الأجمل
مع عملاء مثل كيت ، وأنا أعلم أنني
أنجزت مهمتي في مساعدة
شخص ما على العثور على نفسه ، ما هو جميل
في الوشم هو أنه يكشف
شيئًا ما  عن نفسك على الرغم من أن
الوشم في دياناتنا من المحرمات ، فإن
دياناتنا تتعلق بالسلام
والرحمة ويتجاوز ذلك
قواعد عدم رسم الوشم
لك
[موسيقى]